welcome back to the Rich Eisen show
breaking news from around the NFL we've
got Mark Suster and Dan hanzo's here on
the program we had Chris Wessling and
Greg Rosenthal a couple of weeks ago now
we round out the rest of the around the
NFL podcast with these two gentlemen
studio good to see you guys it's awesome
to be here rich you the Rich Eisen
podcast once upon a time basically
launched the entire podcast industry
inside our building we could remove the
word basically you did that's not much
you got the mic Francesa route where you
got the plaque in WFAN in new york
studio we don't have that it's time it's
like I'm like mo green there's no plaque
there's no sign because damage check
turned it into what club 66 or Studio 66
that's it's it's quite all right
it's great and I love the the success
that you guys have with this with this
pod so when you're watching the games
Sunday it's very Sunday you're you're
ready to go like you do you do them
right off the bat first blush after all
the games correct it's kind of a
scramble because so we're obviously in
our newsroom and you're watching one
game on a big television we have the
European game pass up where you can
watch four live games at the same time
and switch in and out comes right in Cup
well I mean I didn't create the tech but
it's it's nice technology but you're
watching four or five games at a time
we'll divvy them out and then when it
ends we run right up there you know
before the start of Sunday Night
Football do the pods so that we can
actually watch the Sunday Night Football
game that where I talk about it what's
the second half right it's it's crazy
it's so much fun we're very lucky to be
talking football for a living and and
throws throw our thoughts out there as
we are talking the Raiders are going to
take the practice field and I'm we're
assuming number 84 is not gonna be out
there Adam Schefter or former colleague
now with the SPN saying that they're
gonna suspend Antonio Brown cuz he and
our buddy Mayock got into it I mean
we're all shaking our heads right here
but what what are you guys what are your
first blush thought Dan it's it's one of
those things where of course it's
stunning to see the tweet but it's also
not shocking because there was not
breadcrumbs there was big fat t-bone
steaks of a trail leading from how
things ended in Pittsburgh and our
colleague Aditi kingka blah who
covers the Steelers really well and
she's embedded with that team she told
us at the owners meetings how that man
Antonio Brown came in as a humble guy a
no-name out of college and by the time
he finished his run with the Steelers he
was a totally different personality not
a teammate and what's happened is he
went to the Raiders and it's the same
guy
so Oakland at the time it seemed like it
was a good deal and this Steelers got
killed well who's it a good deal for now
I never thought he was gonna make it to
Vegas now is he gonna make it to week
one that's wild well according to our
current colleague Ian Rapoport it never
got physical he had to be restrained
however Antonio Brown did threaten to
punch mike Mayock in the face and then
punted a football and say fined me for
that that is the details of the getting
into it on Wednesday and again um this
is stuff that can be used against him as
conduct detrimental to build a case
should the Oakland Raiders think that
this is a bridge too far to get out of
this contract that if they do not have
to pay him they guarantee dollars he is
owed they could just walk away from him
and say grieve that and that will be the
end of that and now wouldn't you think
they should do something like that right
now
I think they should because it's almost
it reminds me in a much more darker
dramatic arc than what we've dealt with
with Andrew Luck in the cults is you
have the rest of your organization and
team to deal with and mike Mayock
to me does not seem like someone that
wants to play along and dance with a 17
week drama he you know he's already had
to confront this publicly over and over
it's a big headache and you what are you
going to tell the rest of your team if
you're gonna allow a player to to behave
this way I think that you're right the
Antonio Brown the early career career
hard-working hard practicing super
plugged in Antonio Brown is a different
figure than they're dealing with in
Oakland it's not they probably knew that
there were some extra scenarios with him
but they signed up for something much
more than that I think mike Mayock wants
to put up with right now you should be
able to get out of that money because in
what case can you how could anything be
more extra than this and then a player
attacking the GM because he is
Oh still as you saw in Hard Knocks and I
said that from this desk about a month
ago like fine find the kid that we're
talking about the one that didn't get
any offers out of South Florida except
for Central Michigan who then got
drafted late and balled out became one
of the greats in the history of this
game for the first nine years of a
career fine that guy put him in a new
helmet and go ball out
we saw though on Hard Knocks he still is
working hard I mean he is still one of
those guys that's looking at every
metric to try and get better and gain an
edge and be great it's just that he just
can't stop himself I think from a
self-destructive behavior in some way
shape or form you get fined sometimes
you don't get fined for even though you
get a letter to do that move on don't
post it and try make an enemy of the guy
who did execute the trade on behalf of
the Raiders right I mean this it it
doesn't make any sense yeah to your
point that the insta story was so
unnecessary you're this close to week
one you have to know that that
immediately makes you again the number
one story and the controversial figure
and maybe that's where Antonio Bryant
Browns mindset is in 2019 that that's
become more important than just balling
out and and staying in line and being a
big a good teammate and that's when you
just wonder like what's going on none of
us know him personally and you don't
ever speculate about where a guy is
mentally but it just makes you it makes
you wonder if he is hardwired for
professional football at this stage in
his life which is such a shame because
he's an absolute stud we know that he's
one of the most productive players of
all time and that's why mike Mayock and
Jon Gruden got sucked into it but you
know if they had a time machine I think
we know what would happen now Danny
Ainge is Mark Sessler of around the Lea
around the NFL podcast right here from
the NFL Network on the Rich Eisen show
the best team the NFL would be you want
to mark you want a handle that one film
on blank right there well it's rotated
for me a couple times during the
offseason but I go I look at consistency
I look at a great coach and in a top one
or two front office the Philadelphia
Eagles right now I think they're going
to have you know essentially a
bounce-back season because you dealt
with injuries you
she quarterback for part of last year I
just don't see a lot of weaknesses on
that team I love the way the run I think
they found a way to mix analytics and
player choices team-building coaching
and if Carson Wentz goes 16 games
that's my team I think they start about
six and oh look let's let's back that
one up I've got the schedule right here
in front of you home for Washington
Sunday night at Atlanta home for Detroit
Thursday night at Green Bay home for the
J ETS at Minnesota loss you think that's
six I it's it's a tall order but if
they're the best team in the NFL I think
they can and I believe they had the
Cowboys on primetime after that and I
would I do seem to six and no teams
clash on prime-time long saucy
now why would you say that's a loss at
Minnesota Dan about the Jets let's put a
pin in in your personal how would you
finish the sentence best team in the NFL
is Kansas City Chiefs and I love the
Eagles and I think they have a chance to
go all the way but I just think the
Chiefs are that perfect team that's set
up the way it works with sports
sometimes you'd get the heartbreaking
loss the year before and then you find
your way over the hump and I know their
defense isn't perfect Kansas City but
the offense can be historically great
and I find it very interesting that we
all know the drama on Tyreke Hill when
they take McCall Hardman in the second
round you're assuming they're gonna try
to make the rookie have to have this key
role in offense year one now they get to
find a way to find that speedster his
own roll at his own pace Tyreke Hills
there and then even though the sean
mccoy trade I just or the signing I just
find that Andy Reid is a guy that's
gonna be able to crank back the clock
and McCoy I think he has a role on this
team I think this team could average 34
for 35 points a game potentially and I
think they'll get over the hump this
season that's why I think they're the
best and you could also throw the
Cowboys out there now that Zeke is in
think so and that dak appears to be on a
prove a deal for this year and and so is
the coach and defensively they're
terrific all over the place they're fast
and they're big and they are terrific up
front on both sides of the ball you
could also
make the case for the defending NFC
champion Rams their quarterback is paid
their running back is paid they are
great on both sides of the ball great up
front they've got coaching here play
making the reason why I'm going through
this whole setup is that when it comes
down to it even though their roster may
not be as stacked all over the place
because football is a snap to snap
situation as much as we're talking about
season-long storylines and we're talking
about how great these teams are when you
have the ability like you're say the
Chiefs or as you said mark the Eagles
snap to snap week to week quarter to
quarter nobody's better than Bella
checks Patriots with Grady at the helm
nobody's better and when if they the
Eagles did beat him they needed the
Philly special they needed a lot to work
out yep the Chiefs we all know when
ships come down sure they have one in
Foxborough but when it comes down to it
like last year's AFC Championship game
the Rams another example maybe McVeigh's
better you see to use his phrase it's
just tough not to go in that direction
yeah I find no bigger sham in the NFL
the cycle of awards that come out each
year that we have to search around for a
narrative-driven handout to give someone
else coach of the year when it has been
Belichick 18 out of 20 years at this
point I mean it's just it's it should be
it was like Phil Jackson that way in the
NBA when I was winning all those
championship let's hand it to someone
who took a team you know from 2 and 14
to 9 and 7 well by the way you also got
knocked 49 and nothing in the wild
Belichick just taking you to another
Super Bowl why is he not winning that
award every year it's a huge issue to me
and people are hung up on Tom Brady's
getting old if you look at the numbers
and look at his production last year
maybe he is finally in decline but that
defense might be better than it's been
in years Brady is not gonna fall off a
cliff I love Tony Michelle by the way
Michelle is a great young running back
Gordon this it does feel 13 and 3 and
deep run again but the reason why I took
the Saints over them is that one guy who
can pull out his own Philly special or
take look at Belichick across the way
and certainly stroll up to him
at midfield before the game and not
blink
not bad an eye and he's got his own 40
year old warhorse and he's got his own
offense and he's got his own defense
that's why I just think on that given
day
Sean Payton can do the X's and O's with
Belichick as well as anybody else if
they get there that's the way that's my
mind thing he's one of those two or
three coaches where the coach is such an
advantage to the team and I'd love to
see him give you have two weeks to
prepare for New England and that's
probably the Super Bowl we should have
gotten and would have wanted last year
same thing you know the Saints got
killed by the officiating the Chiefs
just missed getting over the hump well
they come back this year maybe and and
they learn from last year and thrive Dan
hands us mark Sessler few minutes left
with the with 2 1/2 2/4 almost went 2
points of the around the NFL podcast
that you can get we're all podcasts are
downloaded from the NFL Media Group so
let's get into the personal then mark
Sessler your first your Browns this is
as as high an expectation level as I can
remember I mean we might I'm being
serious here like go back to the Sam
Rutigliano years where they enter a
season or the Marty Schottenheimer yeah
alright so I went a little too far back
the Marty Schottenheimer years where you
can sit here and say this team has got
the stuff I give you the floor on that
front it's it is been a surreal
dreamlike offseason because if you're a
Browns fan and you know unless you if
you're 45 and so I lived through those
Schottenheimer years where you you ride
the roller coaster of the wonderful
regular season that ended in the drive
the fumble and then a third sort of
figure less AFC Championship where they
just got wiped out by Elway and the
Broncos a third time disappointment was
always around the corner and there's
been nothing but 20 years of a
slow-motion car crash since so part of
me just wanders all of this is it truly
the greatest joke yet spun by the
football gods and something is around
the corner but here's the difference
because in years past on our show we've
even fallen into narratives where I've
told these guys in a ten-minute speech
that Brandon Weeden was going to turn
the corner or the Johnny Manziel had
overcome his demons but this time
leave you actually have the quarterback
offensive line issues are not because I
think he's well equipped to deal with
offensive line issues and the weapons
around him to be that Cleveland
quarterback they've waited for since
Bernie Kosar I also think that Freddie
kitchens it's not easy to be a
first-year head coach Hall place it is
not we met him and that you know it's
it's ten minutes of face time with him
but over everything that he's had to
deal with since some tough questions
along the way I just think he is who he
is he's a Bill Parcells disciple I think
he's learned a lot I think the veneer of
this sort of aw shucks guy from down
south who kind of you know is whistling
Dixie and telling jokes I think there's
a lot more to Freddie kitchens I think
he's the right coach for this team their
practices during training camp where the
most physical they've had in 20 years
and they've needed that that was not the
case on her huge action those are
pattycake practices so for me I think
they're going in with a fight spirit I
think they believe in themselves and
that's where the belief comes from but
there's still a part of me that thinks
when does the curtain lift and I am the
joke is on me egg once again we'll talk
about trap doors opening with the jet
fan in a second to me there there is no
curtain here what would be a successful
season to you I think it's like you know
they're gonna go through some lumps I
think especially early on they have a
tough primetime heavy slate out of the
gate and they're gonna need some time to
Jael I think the line is concerned I put
them at nine and seven or ten and six as
a wild-card team okay that then wins a
playoff game and has a chance to go into
New England that second playoff game
sorry Chris Brock would we'll see what
they're gonna wake up dangerous and
night here comes Belichick against the
first-time quarterback in a divisional
playoff game Texas with the leather
jackets you know okay now then your
hands just your diehard jet fan I'll
give you the floor on what appears to be
look living on bail is easily the most
talented player that they have suited up
since Curtis Martin there's no two ways
about it defensively
Jamal Adams I love
that guy el presidente the president
music culture changer i have no idea
what gays is gonna do with darn 'old he
says he's throwing the piss out of the
ball what do you think about the jet
season
it's a weird season 2 o'clock as a Jets
fan because there is reason for hope
undoubtedly there
I mean Sam darn 'old and Jamal Adams are
the core that a lot of franchises are
envious of Adam GaSe is a total wild
card as the head coach but everything
we've heard this summer is that gays and
Arnold are clicking and yes it's not
unusual to hear those type of summary
storylines this time of year but on the
offensive side of all they're gonna be
fun to watch I think and rich you go all
the way back with the Jets - when's the
last time the Jets were fun to watch on
offense maybe before Brett Favre tours
biceps over a decade ago and I don't
think there was anything fun about the
farm off and I mean there really wasn't
you know fun to see Brett Favre in a jet
jersey but I got to sit here and think
about LinkedIn his when he had his
breakout season Oh didn't know every
single time he threw it down the field
it was just like you know there was a
little bit of a hope and a prayer it was
exciting to see them destroy the peyton
manning colts in a playoff game though I
know and then there were flashes but
darn 'old is the guy that everybody is
reading Broadway Joe type hoping to
Greenberg I mean we had green mike
Greenberg on the show in New York last
week he said he's gonna make he named
his renamed his two kids Sam and Darnell
you know and so possibly a mistake you
know I I'm skeptical to say the least
here certainly and again this season um
well no but the quarterback is well okay
everyone who I respect talks about how
terrific he is and how what a huge
bright light he is on I say this with
the ultimate respect to everyone here in
Los Angeles that listens to us here
locally Southern California and to my
coordinating producer who loves to fight
on we've seen this story before from USC
quarterback and he ran up the ass of his
line mate on Thanksgiving night against
the the biggest rival eventually okay so
that was I understand that that's the
low point of Sanchez's career to AFC
championship games appearances is
another I need to see I'm not
there yet I just can't be there yet I've
said it to mark before I'm one of those
rare always optimistic Jets fans and it
always leads to more pain but all it
needs to do it all has to work once it
has to be the right guy that comes along
once and that's that's the darn old plan
I guess what keeps the season for me
earthbound for the Jets is that the
defense despite some nice players there
is not gonna is gonna struggle I think
especially against the pass the
offensive line Joe Douglas the general
manager is gonna need some time to put
this together and have a full offseason
I think they could hang in the race
though in December I think this could be
a nine win team potentially if
everything breaks white right maybe you
win ten and you get to the playoffs
I'd be amazing and then next year you
could spin forward and say maybe this is
the way people are excited about the
Browns of the if Douglas has a nice
offseason then you get all in on the
Jets but for now I see it stills the
Patriots the vision its Tom Brady's
where all the Jets are still just living
in it Dan is still very don't let him
fool you very annoyed about that Browns
Jets game from last year and the way
that that went if they don't beat the
Browns in week two I'm not sure our
friendship indoors to be on it's a long
front good friendship and if you're
gonna passive-aggressively snipe at me
I'll have to let let rich know that
Marc's firstborn son was named after
Colt McCoy here's the great timing I we
named him he was born in the morning
Colt McCoy that was draft day that night
they drafted Brandon Weeden so you know
we like the name outside of that I will
by the way hot tip you Dan for that
trolling actually also and to you Mark
because you were came on as well I will
give you this at least your son wasn't
born when Spurgeon win was the
quarterback you'll always have that Wow
you always said about levy on bail big
time mad and we should just bring this
all full circle while Antonio Brown is
melting down in Oakland levy on bail
with the exception of not showing up for
for voluntary workouts has been a model
jet from all shapes and sizes sound
totally that's gonna prove people are
and all that and he's on game day
morning with the Steve Smith on Sunday
and you could check out around the NFL
Podcast three times a week correct and
and we're all podcasts are are taken in
from the NFL media group good to have
you guys here we'll have you during the
safe that's mark Sessler and Dan hands
who's here on the Rich Eisen show for
more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on be our live or download the Rich
Eisen show app